you do so many characters on Kroll show
and and so many varied characters I just
wanted to talk about him for a second
find out where the inspirations may be
like there's bryan lacroix yes
who's I guess modeled after Justin
Bieber yes yeah he's sort of a Justin
Bieber Austin Mahone character and you
know Justin Bieber's getting roasted
here you know he's getting a roast and
bryan lacroix is getting roasted in
Canada right but in candidates called a
addressing doom addressing dad but
they're really gonna go right that's
gonna be rough they are gonna be so
polite to him but there's like Austin
Mahone as the mo homeys Justin Bieber as
the Beliebers and Bryan Lacroix has the
Bryant ologists this character right
here is a lot like pitbull yes tell us
about him his name is sing your feature
he features on everybody song yes and he
also likes to feet and he's strapped in
a green screen prison oh is yeah yeah
that's a favorite detail I'm trapped in
a green screen prison of moral design
and then body of Bobby Bobby
bottleservice a fan favorite is he yeah
you do some characters but you just want
to punch their yeah thing is Bobby
bottleservice based on a real person
he's based on a bunch of people but
there's now a guy on Survivor this
season named Rodney who gives a speech
about how much he loves his mother and
it's like they stole Bobby bottleservice
and made him a real person a real guy
yeah there's a real guy do we have it or
no clip here brought a clip of someone
else's show if you go back to where I'm
from the number one person number one
love of my life I don't have to grow
my mother my mother will tell you I'm
the biggest sweetheart oakdale okay I'm
just stating facts human being is just
stating fact
you